il n'y a pas de de gens simples et des
gens compliqués il y a des gens
à Niro vous aussi vous avez évolué sur
le plan social par rapport à vos
grands-parents et oui c'est le sujet de
mon livre en fait mon grand-père enfin
mes deux côtés mes grands-parents
étaient des gens extrêmement en pauvres
était enfin mon grand-père était
maternel était illettré et il travaille
dans les fermes il y avait pas d'autres
solutions mon père a commencé aussi à
travailler dans les fermes et ensuite il
était juste rouge immense utilisé dans
une petite usine il était ouvrier très
longtemps et ensuite je crois jusqu'à
peu près jusqu'à la guerre donc il avait
40 ans elle essaie de trouver à 40 ans
et ça ma mère avait pris un commerce
avec un commerce tous les deux mais très
très enfin qui marchait plus ou moins
bien et qui est dans un quartier ouvrier
et ensuite à la guerre mon père a cessé
son emploi d'ouvriers pour il est devenu
enfin en 45 vraiment établir son compte
avec ma mère mais c'est toujours été
c'est un commerce un café épicerie tout
à fait
qui marchait qui marchait bien c'est ce
n'est pas absolument pas la pauvreté
mais il devait travailler très très dur
c'était aucun doute il y avait une
concurrence terrible voilà et il est
mort en 76 au terme d'une petite
ascension sociale parce que pour lui
c'était une petite ascension sociale mes
parents ont toujours pensé que il
fallait moi aussi je pense que on tousse
ici on peut dire une chose c'est dans la
société divisée où on est où il y a une
échelle sociale je crois qu'on a employé
le mot bien quand on est au bas de
l'échelle on a qu'une envie c'est de
monter je crois qu'il n'y a pas d'autre
et la solution qui apparaît qui est
apparue presque toujours c'était les
études il faudrait dire maintenant que
ça n'est plus vrai que c'est de plus en
plus difficile mais il est très
longtemps ça a été ça a été les études
et pour moi effectivement ça a été le
moyen de comme on dit s'en sortir voilà
et alors pourquoi vous avez écrit ce
livre
d'abord pour
réhabiliter le mode de vie de mes
parents vous savez vous avez dit que
votre grand-père était un homme simple
je crois c'est un mot que je hais il n'y
a pas de gens sains simples et des gens
compliqués il y a des gens et j'ai trop
j'ai employé moi-même ce mot-là de dire
mes parents sont simples c'est affreux
d'employé ce mot-là ce sont nos parents
il n'y a pas de c'est se mettre dans la
peau au fond des autres qui vous
regardent et que vous disent oui on voit
bien vos parents sont simples je pense
qu'il y a des gens c'est tout alors je
voulais réhabiliter et dire ce que mon
père avait été tout ce qui est des
choses que normalement on considère de
manière de se laver sa manière de lire
le journal ce qui les met que c'est
goûts réel et que ça soit présenté non
pas avec condescendance mais que ce soit
présenté aux façons contraire normale
oui
on ne dit pas des gens simples mais
quand on parle depuis le début d'échelle
sociale avec le bas de l'échelle et le
haut de l'échelle très bien la même
chose on fait la même chose c'est-à-dire
qu'on est obligé d'employer un certain
langage je crois que c'est ce langage
qui on devrait changer je sais pas si
vous êtes d'accord mais oui c'est ça si
vous voulez alors là en disant on a eu
des parents simples et bien au fond on
leur fait un affront terrible je crois
qu'on leur fait un affront épouvantable
et que c'est pas ça qu'il faut dire on a
eu des parents ils étaient mon
grand-père était illettré voilà il était
illettré c'était pas sa faute et donc je
crois que c'est une chose à dire
à l'école à poursuivre des études ce qui
était un peu rare dans notre milieu
est-ce que c'était l'ambition de vos
parents ou c'était vous qui avez envie
je crois que étant enfant on ne pense
pas on
fait ces enfin on va à l'école c'est
encore un jeu l'école hein je crois
qu'il faut pas dire alors par contre mes
parents trouvaient ça très très
important mais moi je trouvais ça c'est
amusant si vous voulez c'est parce que
ça me plaisait j'avais pas l'impression
d'accomplir mais ça compte beaucoup je
pense que les parents qui se
désintéressent absolument
sûrement que bien sûr ils sont pas
motivés ils sont pas motivés surtout si
les parents ne sont pas eux-mêmes ne
sont pas les mêmes cultivés entre
guillemets bien sûr encore une fois
[Musique]